JZ is setting off truth bombs about his
marriage
JLo's bromance with a-rod is heating up
Plus stranger things get a creepy teaser
poster what we know about season 2
spoiler alert I'm not in it
I'm just auditioning for season 3 hi
friends this is the daily Deni and
that's how you quick change
today is July 7th aka 7/11 day and no
I'm not talking about the Slurpees how
fitting that Beyonce has a song named
after this date because her husband is
making headlines again as he unleashes
more truth about his marriage to Beyonce
and it's a sign of hope we don't see
very often J released a mini documentary
he's calling a footnote for his latest
album 444 in a candid jay-z breaks down
the inspiration behind the album's title
track which if you listen to it appears
to allude to cheating and even
references forgiveness after infidelity
again this is my real life you know like
I just ran into this place and we built
this big beautiful mansion of of a
relationship you know I mean that wasn't
totally built on the hundred percent
true and then it stopped cracking you
know and being things start happening
that the public can see you know I'm
saying then we had to go to a point okay
tear this down now let's start from the
beginning and it's hard J goes on to say
that rebuilding their relationship was
by far the hardest thing he's ever had
to do and with that fans like me are
given the other side of lemonade and yet
another piece of this complicated puzzle
about their marriage somebody call NBC
because I've got a pitch for their next
live musical speaking of Jennifer Lopez
is set to play Rosie and Bye Bye Birdie
live for NBC that was postponed for the
end of 2018 because Jenny's block is
busy she just dropped the hot new music
video for her Spanish single me tsuneo
and JLo is on fire once again proven she
can really wear anything
[Music]
now I robbed two different looks today
but JLo rocks ten in his video trust me
I watched his three times and counted
now the video was shot in Miami Florida
where Jennifer has been hanging with her
man a rod at the MLB all-star game it's
a work trip for him but our new favorite
couple have not been shy about showing
some PDA JLo is in his world but clearly
holding her own in fact a rod said on
Instagram live that j.lo has watched
more baseball in the last few months
than in her entire life
that's probably because it's the first
time in a very long time she has not
dated another musician or a dancer and
just check out mama Lopez hanging with
a-rod and his daughters Ella and Natasha
how do you like the new song Monday on
Monday tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow we if
that doesn't earn them a 9 on the John
and Chrissy scale I don't know what will
all right moving right along to the show
I am counting the days for to return
this fall stranger things a new teaser
for season 2 has touched down on us the
ominous poster features the four boys
staring at a dark red storm forming over
their town of Hoskins Indiana other than
that it doesn't give too much away
except the release date October 27
people now I know that seems far away
but here's what we know about this next
season season two takes place in 1984 a
year after the events in the first
season
according to the official description
from Netflix the citizens of Hawkins
Indiana are still reeling from the
horrors of the demo Gorgon and the
secrets of the Hawkins lab roll Byers
has been rescued from the upside down
but a bigger sinister entity still
threatens those who survived
and that threat might be more than
supernatural there are four new
characters including Max and her brother
Billy and here with the Duffy brothers
aka the show's producers had to sing
about Billy when he T caught up with
them just last month we really wanted a
human villain did you know year I mean
we always talk about speeding King but
he always has the human villains are
often scarier than the monsters and so
we wanted to introduce a human character
who will scare the crap on it
stranger things executive producer Shawn
Levy also told us that next season will
definitely be spookier scarier and
bigger in its action and spectacle well
we'll have to wait until October 27th
when all nine episodes drop but one
thing's for sure I am ready for some
more of that kooky Winona Ryder
speaking of kooky joining us now is our
resident bachelorette expert and host of
Rosa drodze here on e to YouTube or
demon girl The Bachelor returned after a
mini break for a week and our girl
rachel is just four dudes away from
picking the one is he in this patch what
did your take right now I mean Winona
when she's on that award show and like
she wasn't looking to speed um yes okay
if anything is scarier than stranger
saying it's the Bachelorette right now
because who is Rachel going to pick you
guys I love Peter so much but the thing
is do we want Rachel to be engaged and
we know she's engaged or do we want him
to be the next Bachelor
it's so hard to can't you know why he
would make a very good bachelor but also
she is spending for him I know but I
think she wanted me to now try and take
see what's going on paper or what's
going to move Oh
okay Lauren that's enough you can catch
Lauren school rose a silk recap of the
Bachelorette on roses Rose a every
Tuesday on ETV YouTube channel there's a
new episode up now when I like in my
masters go say thanks
alright you guys hit subscribe so you
don't miss an episode of that and of
course we are cooking up some juicy
stories over at ET online.com so come
check us out see you tomorrow amigos I'm
going to shimmy wet my way after i
couldnt even finish that line you guys